there are strong indications tonight
that you will get to see a classified
memo that Republicans say details
surveillance abuses by the intelligence
community during its investigation of
the Trump presidential campaign but so
far that document is still under lock
and key the FBI director is pushing back
publicly saying this memo should not
come out and tonight we learn just how
raw emotions were in the House
Intelligence Committee meeting Monday
about this memo chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge has
some amazing quotes tonight good evening
Catherine thank you bread late today the
House Intelligence Committee released
the 51 page transcript that shows
Monday's vote to release the Republican
drafted memo was acrimonious at times
bitter with allegations flying from
Democrats in this exchange Congressman
Mike Quigley presses Committee Chairman
Devin Nunez over whether he coordinated
with the White House Quigley did they
have any idea you were doing this did
they talk about doing this with you did
you suggest it to them Nunez I would
just answer as far as I know no and I
would also say that we are well aware
that the minority has not wanted to
conduct this investigation by the public
opposition to the subpoenas that we
issued back in August that we're clearly
looking into matters of FISA abuse in a
statement after the transcripts released
the committee's ranking Democrat Adam
Schiff highlighted the passage because a
follow-up question about staff
coordination was not answered earlier
today the feud between the FBI Justice
Department and Capitol Hill took a new
turn with the bureau issuing a rare
public statement claiming the four-page
memo is misleading and incomplete
because facts are missing it reads in
part the FBI was provided a limited
opportunity to review this memo the day
before the committee voted to release it
as expressed during our initial review
we have grave concerns about material
omissions of fact that fundamentally
impact the memos accuracy Nunez quickly
disputed the claim and seized on how
long it took the FBI and Justice
Department facing contempt of Congress
to comply having stonewalled Congress's
demands for information for nearly a
year it's no surprise to see the FBI and
DOJ issues spurious objections to
allowing the American people to see
information related to surveillance
abuses at these agencies and in what
appears to be a reference to the Trump
dossier funded by the Clinton campaign
in DNC Nunez continues it's clear that
top officials used unverified
information in a court document to fuel
a counterintelligence investigation
during an American political campaign
FBI director Christopher Rea and Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosenstein were at
the White House earlier this week and a
source close to the matter says both men
have voiced their concerns about the
memo with Rosen Stein quote pushing back
hard the president seemed to make his
feelings known after State of the Union
the committee had no comment today on a
possible timing for the release of the
memo and in the last few minutes we've
gotten some new information that gives
us some context an FBI director
Christopher Ray's review on Capitol Hill
Sunday of the four page memo we're now
told he had an hour and a half so 90
minutes to look at that four page
document Brett okay Katherine more on
this with the panel thank you I